if you've been following the blue blur
since his debut in the early 90s you
probably caught most of the Easter eggs
in his feature film debut if you're a
more casual fan there are bound to be a
couple you missed just like Sonic
himself they go by pretty fast before
Sonic arrives on earth he lives in a
lush green paradise modeled after the
first level of his debut video game more
on that in a moment
unfortunately young Sonic's blissful
existence doesn't last long it turns out
that everybody wants Sonic's SuperSpeed
including a tribe of animals that chase
Sonic from his home planet to ours those
aren't just any critters chasing Sonic
through the prologue though they're
members of the knuckles clan a tribe of
echidnas that originally appeared in
Archie comics record busting Sonic the
Hedgehog line the most popular member of
the clan to us is Sonic's Ally knuckles
who was named after the tribe clearly
the Sonic the Hedgehog movies take on
the knuckles clan is a little different
from the comics lore but it's still cool
to see them pop up if they lead to an
appearance by knuckles himself in the
sequel even better but what you really
need is some serious muscle you mean me
right right most of Sonic the Hedgehog
takes place in a sleepy Montana town
called Green Hills which was established
in 1981 just a couple of years before
Sega released its very first video game
console nothing much happens there at
least not until the little blue alien
who calls Green Hills home gets angry
and attracts the government's attention
Green Hills is an appropriate place for
Sonic's adventure to start given that
it's named after the first level of the
inaugural Sonic the Hedgehog video game
when Genesis owners booted up Sonic the
Hedgehog in 1991 Green Hill Zone was the
first location that players visited
since then Green Hill zones grassy
slopes angular palm trees and unstable
cliffs have gone on to become one of the
franchise's most recognizable sites
since Sonic the Hedgehog the Green Hill
Zone has reappeared in Sonic Adventure 2
sonic forces sonic mania Sonic
Generations Super Smash Brothers and
plenty of other games you can even build
a papercraft version of the Green Hill
Zone if you want the Green Hill Zone is
one of the most famous levels in all of
gaming and it's
good thing it's in the movie it just
wouldn't be Sonic without it
Sonic the Hedgehog has a large and
extremely dedicated fanbase that loves
to express itself
unfortunately fans abilities don't
always live up to their passion spend a
few minutes browsing deviantART and
you'll see what we mean there's an
upside though as terrible as some Sonic
fan art is it's a great source of memes
some of which have become just as famous
as Sonic himself even the official Sonic
the Hedgehog Twitter account has gotten
in on the fun and naturally the movie
does as well early in the film green
hills resident kook crazy Karl shows off
a crude rendering of the Blue Devil a
not so mythical creature that only Karl
knows exists well if you've spent any
time on the internet you'll recognize
Carl's drawing immediately it's a very
close recreation of the infamous sanic
Hedgehog the star of a surreal YouTube
video who starred as a nightmarish
picture of Sonic and has become a
character all of his own later when
Sonic wakes up from a Robotnik induced
stupor he exclaims gotta go fast before
racing all over a suburban San Francisco
home that's also a meme in 2008 and
endearingly awful drawing of Sonic
adorned with the phrase gotta go fast
which originated in Sonic X's title
theme appeared on the fan site Sonic
central ever since gottagofast has been
a rallying cry for fans of bad fan art
and often appears on parodies mimicking
the original drawings weird blobby
hedgehog back in the days when Genesis
did what Nintendo not every kid knew
that Sonic was way cooler than Mario
just look at the evidence Sonic could
move much faster than Nintendo's fat
lazy plumber supposedly thanks to the
Genesis much hyped and mostly bogus
blast processing capabilities not only
that but Sonic had ninety style attitude
despair when you booted up Sonic the
Hedgehog the title character greeted you
with a cocky grin if he left him
standing in one place for too long he'd
tap his foot shoot you a dirty look and
in Sonic the Hedgehog 2 and later titles
impatiently check his watch Sonic's
irreverent idle animation has become
suitably iconic and while been
Schwartz's big screen version of the
character isn't as caught
as a 16-bit iteration he's just as
impatient near the end of the movie when
Sonic is facing down Jim Carrey's dr.
Robotnik the manic scientist launches a
flurry of rockets at the furry hero
except is someone who moves as fast as
Sonic and attack like that is no problem
as he waits for the rockets to hit sonic
taps his foot and checks his watch
exactly like he does in the game before
leaping into action you might know him
best as dr. Ivo Robotnik
but in Japan Sonic's arch nemesis was
originally called Eggman in fact as
Takashi Iizuka the head of Sega's Sonic
Team tells game informer that's what the
people behind Sonic's video games still
call him as Iizuka tells the story Sega
of America changed the characters name
while localizing Sonic the Hedgehog
without consulting the character's
creators first unfortunately when Sonic
became popular the name Robotnik stuck
eventually frustrated by having to deal
with the villains dual identity Sonic
Team decided to make Evo Robotnik the
villains canonical name and Eggman his
nickname the mad scientist has been
known by both monikers ever since I just
thought you might like a latte with
steamed Austrian goat milk of course I
would a latte
Sonic the Hedgehog also pays tribute to
egg man's dual identity as the movie
nears its climax Sonic mocks Jim
Carrey's Robotnik by nicknaming him
Eggman although he comes by the name a
little differently than the developers
did in the games Robotnik is impossibly
round giving him an egg-like appearance
in the film Sonic has a habit of giving
people food based nicknames just ask Tom
donut Lord which house key if you don't
believe us so when he realizes that some
of Robotnik's drones look like eggs well
he really has no other choice in the
video games the main soldiers and dr.
Robotnik's mechanical army are cyborgs
creatures known as badniks
powered by live animals which they use
like batteries the badniks roams Sonic's
home world searching for Chaos Emeralds
building super weapons like the Death
Egg and doing everything they can to
stop Sonic and his friends unfortunately
while Robotnik uses a number of
technological terrors to wage war on
Sonic and Tom the badniks don't appear
in the Sonic the Hedgehog movie however
they could have
apparently Robotnik has already made
them later in the movie when he's trying
to harness the power from Sonic's
supercharged quill Robotnik accidentally
shorts out his mobile headquarters when
he opens the fuse box to restart the
device we see a few different switches
each of which are labeled with pieces of
masking tape what does one of them say
why badniks
of course okay okay there's only one way
you missed this easter egg you walked
out of the theater as soon as the end
credits started
if so shame on you you missed the most
crowd-pleasing moment in the entire
movie not to mention the appearance of
one of the most popular sonic characters
of all time yes that's right after Sonic
the Hedgehog's pixel art credits
sequence ends none other than Sonic's
number one sidekick and best friend nan
Tom edition miles tails Prower makes his
theatrical debut with a gust of wind
tails appears out of what seems to be
another interplanetary portal it turns
out that tails is searching for Sonic
and while he's happy that the Hedgehog
is nearby he's also worried as he soars
off into the distance
tails mutters to himself has he found
Sonic too late too late for what sadly
we don't know not yet anyway if Sonic
the Hedgehog is a box-office success the
sequel should answer that question and
put tails front and center here's hoping
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and TV shows are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the belt so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]